vocês
[Aplausos]
boa noite a entrega do Prêmio
Nobel de Literatura a Bob Dylan causou
considerável controvérsia e debate o que
Dylan aceitaria o prêmio se ele tivesse
sido em primeira instância sabemos agora
[Música]
ele aceitará o prêmio à sua
maneira  a segunda e mais interessante
questão permanece em aberto que o debate sobre
Dylan e os nobres não é o
tema principal da minha palestra esta noite
mas dá-nos um bom começo
já foi dito que Dylan não é um
escritor suficientemente bom para ganhar o Nobel  Prêmio
que existem muitos outros
escritores melhores escritores mais merecedores que
deveriam ter recebido o prêmio e
tais julgamentos de valor são notoriamente
difíceis de provar ou refutar, mas
acho que pode-se dizer que
Dylan, mesmo que ele não seja o grande escritor
que alguns  algumas pessoas pensam que ele
é um escritor muito bom e ele é certamente
um escritor melhor do que muitos ganhadores anteriores do
Nobel, outros disseram que premiar
o Prêmio Nobel  ize para Dylan foi uma espécie de
erro de categoria até mesmo uma falta de decoro
o Dylan não é um verdadeiro escritor que ele
é um compositor uma estrela do rock e então
alguém que não pertence ao
domínio da alta cultura
naquelas e naquelas encostas superiores do monte
parnassus lar das musas e daqueles
que as musas favoreceram hum, eu posso
respeitar esses argumentos de alguns deles
de qualquer forma, mas no final das contas eu os
rejeitaria para mim, a decisão de conceder
o Prêmio Nobel a Dylan foi apropriada,
perspicaz e corajosa no
faz parte da comissão sueca acho que é
bom para a literatura é bom para
o Prémio Nobel e é bom para o
estudo literário aqui em
Portugal e noutros lugares e digo-
vos isto não a alguém que tenha sido um
admirador de delle Erbe Dylan  um fã, se
quiser, dos anos 1960, embora seja o
caso, mas também como alguém que foi
por muitos anos, alternadamente, aluno,
estudioso, professor e crítico de
literatura como verdadeiros
estudos literários  insider eu acho que isso
que é importante que nós temos
que apreciar o Dylan é o que
estamos vendo Dylan é aqui a visão sobre o
ponto a frente é justamente essa visão
de um insider que Dylan I 30 se o
prêmio eu acho  é bom para os
estudos literários porque nos permite abrir
para ir em frente para ir mais alto
eu sou aquele negócio do dylan me desculpe eu tento
começar de novo que o prêmio do Dylan é
o prêmio para o Dylan é que o texto se foi
fora da minha cabeça eles são o prémio tem
sido um acho que como digo
provocou polémica mas o pé para algumas
pessoas vê-o como o fim dos
estudos literários mas acho que
veria quase como um novo começo que estão a
oferecer  a perspectiva de um novo começo
estou envolvido em estudos literários
há como digo há quase 50 anos
acredito na literatura acredito nos
valores literários e gostaria que fosse
realmente nessa base que eu gostaria
de ver que eu  estou feliz em ver Bob
Dylan conseguir  A palavra e para mim e muitas das
críticas que foram feitas
acima fizeram o suficiente para que o problema
esteja com elas não é tanto que
estejam erradas, mas que estejam fora de
questão o prêmio nobel de literatura
não é o equivalente literário  de uma
medalha de ouro olímpica ou de um desses
oscars que defendem um
serviço diferenciado para a indústria
e não o que é é algo que eu
acho que é um prêmio de literatura um
prêmio que estimula amplia e aprofunda
nossa conversa sobre literatura
é é o  indivíduo premiado é
realmente apenas a ocasião do prêmio é
se não fosse que seria
difícil
pensar em levar a sério e dado esse
Bob Dylan desafiador desafiador
transgressor é um eu acho que
um amuleto Lee é uma pessoa eminentemente apropriada
para receber esse prêmio hum  como eu disse meu
envolvimento com os estudos literalmente
vem de muito longe eu sou alguém que
eu me consideraria como uma espécie
de tradição  alista, como digo, acredito
na literatura, acredito na
centralidade da literatura para a educação
e, além disso, acredito nos
valores literários, ou seja, acredito que a
literatura é uma coisa por direito próprio,
tendo como Aristóteles insistiu que eles têm
seus próprios padrões de
padrões de correção que não são os
mesmos que se aplicam em outras artes ou em
outras áreas da atividade humana também
acredito que literatura é que
alguns livros são melhores que outros que
alguma literatura é melhor mais valiosa
mais útil que outras Datak Dillon é
parte disso, embora eu acredite nessas
coisas, também reconheço que, se os
estudos literários devem continuar e espero muito
que isso aconteça, isso deve mudar, não podemos
continuar fazendo sempre a mesma coisa
, não podemos nos tornar curadores e
guardiões de uma fração das
obras canônicas  estão acreditando zelosamente guardando o
acesso a essas encostas superiores do monte
parnaso se fizermos isso nos tornaremos como
as figuras que Dante descreve no de
vul  gari eloquentia vamos
andando pelas ruas como cegos
vendo atrás de nós o que de fato está
à nossa frente talvez a pergunta que deveríamos
fazer não é quem entra quem fica de fora
quem é permitido quem não é mas Chris
custodiet Ipsos custódias que guarda os
Guardiões  Acho que temos que ter esse
grau de autoconsciência sobre isso
se você gosta e Dante Dante é a
eloquentia bulgari que acabamos de
referenciar é um trabalho que veio em um momento
em que uma grande mudança de paradigma uma
mudança de paradigma que produziu a
literatura vernacular e  a cultura do
vernáculo cultura literária nossa
literatura nossa cultura a mudança que
estávamos olhando não é da
mesma ordem de grandeza, mas com certeza os
tempos estão mudando e acho que
essa é uma perspectiva positiva e empolgante
estudos literários  no século 21
devemos mudar com eles devemos ser
mais abertos mais menos exclusivos devemos estar
preparados para permitir que muitas coisas nela
antes talvez tenham sido excluídas nós
devemos  aprender o talvez a reconhecer que a
literatura não é mais o que nós agora o
que pensávamos que era talvez
nunca tenha sido o que pensávamos que era e
e eu acho que vamos em frente a partir
daí não estou defendendo um movimento  para
estudos culturais e certamente não para
emburrecimento eu não ensino Bob Dylan
porque ele é popular ou porque ele é
fácil na verdade é muito para o
país
mas a palavra estrada é importante no trabalho de Bob
Dylan é um motivo recorrente ou
tema recorrente  é um item importante
no inventário do mobiliário de sua
mente e liga Bob Dylan fundamenta
o trabalho de Dylan na cultura popular pense na
rota 66 e no cotidiano
dos Estados Unidos contemporâneos a
rodovia é a coordenada do Karma com a
rua mas as rodovias de Dylan  são também
estradas altas que conduzem ao alto
inclusive aos cumes do Parnassus
e de vez em quando permitem uma
transcendência fordyce também precisa lembrar
que o velho ponto no estudo literário
O preço máximo que nunca pode
suportar nunca é nenhum ensino
ou aprendizado direto sobre literatura literatura
é um conhecimento objetivo não um
estudo subjetivo o que ensinamos são
estudos literários não William Shakespeare
ou TS Eliot ou Bob Dylan e o que estou
defendendo não é  realmente qualquer coisa
terrivelmente você ou chocante até certo ponto
Dylan está nos estudos literários
há muito tempo em 2004 o professor
Richard Thomas um classicista de Harvard
começou a ministrar um seminário que mas Dylan
ao lado de Homer e Virgil o eminente
erudito crítico professor Christopher
rich Rick é de longa data  o defensor de
Dylan produziu um grande volume um grande
volume acadêmico chamado as
visões de pecados de Bob Dylan eu poderia multiplicar os
exemplos mas vou avançar para
o final em direção à minha conclusão com
uma nota pessoal alguém
me perguntou recentemente como quando eu  tinha as músicas de Dylan
na década de 1960 quando adolescente eu
reconheci
sua poesia mas a resposta é sim eu reconheci
lá estavam  e não como a outra poesia sobre
você ou a outra poesia que encontrei,
mas eu as reconheci como poesia e
acho que isso foi particularmente verdadeiro
no caso de Dylan é uma das
pinturas de Dylan de uma exposição
cintura alta Dylan's Highways isso é
particularmente verdadeiro  das grandes músicas
que Dylan produziu em 1965 1966 esses
álbuns trazem tudo de volta para casa Highway 61
revisitado loira sobre loira que seria
minha lista de grandes canções de Dylan que você poderia
fazer o seu próprio e o crítico literário irlandês
Declan Teibert lembra que quando
ouviu pela primeira vez  essas músicas soaram
como algo vindo em uma mensagem
de outro planeta e eu sei exatamente o
que ele quer dizer eu nunca tinha ouvido nada
parecido com elas antes eu acho que nunca
ouvi nada parecido com elas desde então e isso
nem eram nada  ou eles eram
muito parecidos com a poesia que eu conhecia, mas
na verdade de uma maneira estranha eu novamente reconheço
que eles exigiam a mesma forma e
qualidade de atenção que terá que
ser dada a eles?  poesia da escola para Virgílio e
Shakespeare que a atenção não era dada
nas salas de aula, mas ouvindo discos
com meus amigos na sala da frente da casa da minha
mãe fumando um
cigarro clandestino tomando café e
tentando descobrir o que diabos eram essas
coisas mais tarde eram intermináveis
debates divagantes em dormitórios e bares de estudantes Bob
Dylan me ensinou a ler e não apenas a
ler Bob Dylan a necessidade a necessidade de encontrar
um sentido em Bob Dylan soma dar sentido
ao mundo isso é o que a literatura
pode fazer
isso às vezes é o que os estudos literários
podem  fazer depois tentei passar isso para os
outros é o que faço por que faço
bem feito isso não é uma pergunta tão fácil
Dylan Thomas o poeta galês e algumas
pessoas dizem que o jovem Robert
Zimmerman adotou o nome Dylan como um
ato de homenagem  para aquele poeta Dylan Thomas
escreveu no prefácio de seus
poemas coletados que ele disse ter ouvido falar
de um pastor que foi perguntado por que ele
estava em peludo sentou em anéis peludos ele fez rit
observâncias à lua para proteger seus
rebanhos e o pastor respondeu que eu seria um
tolo se não fizesse o que faço e
seria um tolo se pensasse
[Aplausos]
você